SCP-096 Vs SCP-689.
The monster whose face you never want to see
illuminated vs the mass-murdering haunter
of the dark.
Who would win, the Shy Guy or this Sinister
Statue?
689 is a small soapstone statue that puts
anyone who sees it in grave danger.
Once they first see it, the second they look
away, they’ll be instantly killed, and the
statue will appear sitting on their corpse.
And of course, SCP-096 will mercilessly hunt
down and eviscerate anyone who makes the mistake
of seeing its face.
But despite the danger of both anomalies,
we call this one a draw.
Why?
The statue can’t see, and thus, wouldn’t
activate 096’s rage state.
Also, one of the popular theories about 096
is that it’s actually blind, meaning it
would never see and activate 689 either.
The two may just awkwardly stand around until
something else happened!